i'm back
um
so
i'm going to talk about c groups and
i've been talking about c groups to
people for years
but i'm going to talk about them for the
first time in a way that i've not talked
about them before which is
my presentation's voice gone before this
is secrets version one which you're all
using
and here's what's going to change in
secrets version two
but now secrets version 2 has really
arrived so
i'm just going to say here's c groups by
the way this is version two
and i'm not going to tell you about
version one
um soon it'll
well for some of us at least it'll be a
distant memory
for some of us with embedded products
perhaps not
alrighty so um
a little bit of introduction um i'm the
maintainer of the linux manual pages
project this is the project that
documents system calls and c library
functions i've been doing this for a
while
and i wrote a lot of those pages as well
i wrote a book
these days um i i my primary business
i'm a trainer by background though i'm
i'm a software engineer
and the stuff i'm going to talk about in
this slot is sort of an introduction to
you know what is it what are c groups
an example or two
then a discussion of the kinds of things
that we can control with c groups and
there's various things that we can
control
um and then a little bit of the
mechanics about how how c groups well in
particular secrets version two work how
you enable and disable controllers
um and um
manage controls to different levels of
granularity in when you're managing
processes and then there's another slot
that comes after this which talks about
some of the
more
fine-grained details about how c-groups
work
okay so a little bit of history
c groups it's been around as a feature
for a long time started in 2006 there
was a feature developed internally on
google's kernels
but soon afterwards it got released into
the mainline linux
kernel and at the beginning of 2008.
at the beginning there were three
controllers that were all sort of cpu
related functionality but pretty quickly
various other controllers got added
because people looked on this idea and
they saw that it was good and they
wanted one too
the thing is the way this was done was
a
diverse groups who did their own thing
added their own controller for the thing
that they wanted to control and there
was no sort of
global oversight no coordination no one
managing all of this everyone did their
own thing and added their own bit
and
very soon things turned into a mess
as i like to say
there's many examples of this in linux
decentralized design failed us
again
it didn't take long for people to
realize there was a mess here and
already
by 2012 not only are people recognized
as a mess we're going to fix it and the
way we're going to fix it is let's do it
do it over again
so 2012 the work starts already by 2015
system d supports secrets version 2
which is even before it is officially
released in 2016.
um so
2016 four years later secrets version 2
is officially released but it's
incomplete what i mean by that is
there's
a lot of controllers that were present
in version one
that were not yet present in version two
and
crucially for example there was no cpu
controller in secrets version 2 and that
was a big blocker for many people
because that was that's an important
controller
but things did progress and by 2019
fedora becomes the first distribution to
switch to using secrets version 2 by
default
docker adds cigarettes version 2 support
in 2020
and
suddenly everyone else is rushing onto
the bandwagon as well all the other
distributions this year pretty much are
switching to sea groups version two by
default so um ubuntu just switched days
ago
debian a few months ago arch further
back in time but i think it was this
year might have been last year
other distributions
either they've switched already or
they're going to switch soon
so
there is a lot of existing
infrastructure that depends on secrets
version one but there's been a lot of
migration work done as well and so
that's why i'm going to ignore
secrets version one just talk about
serious version two i'm gonna pretend
that version one doesn't exist
nevertheless it could well be that when
you boot up your linux system you're
booting into cigarettes version one by
default
and you actually want to do some of this
stuff try it out in secrets version two
probably the easiest thing for you to do
is
reboot your system so you actually use
secrets version two by default after
boot and there's a couple of ways that
you can um
do this oh and by the way you can tell
what you perhaps have when you boot up
by grabbing to see how many c group
lines there are in your proc mountains
file and if there's more than one
you probably need to re-boost
and
when you reboot
you can use one of two boot options you
know that the grub command line
either you can say
disable secrets version one
system d will then take that as a signal
to say i only need to use secrets
version two
alternatively
instead of disabling secrets version one
in the kernel you can tell system d hey
just use c groups version two and then
it during the boot up process it only
mounts c groups version 2. it doesn't
bother trying to mount series version 1.
either way works but the second way you
could still use secrets version 1 if you
felt inclined
once we've booted
the c group file system and this is the
point really that the interface to c
groups is a pseudo file system and that
pseudo file system is mounted at a
certain location um either cis fsc group
or csfs
c group unified depending
how we've booted it'll be at one of
those locations
the pseudo file system that's mounted is
a
file system of type c group 2.
this
file system this mount point is
sometimes called the unified hierarchy
and the contrast here is with c groups
version one
in cigarettes version two there is only
one file system but in the secrets
version one there were many file systems
in use many hierarchies this was
pretty messy and so
one of the science decisions in secrets
version 2 is let's have one hierarchy
and people call it the unified hierarchy
so what is this thing
c groups essentially two components a
way of hierarchically grouping processes
so you can have
c groups that have child c groups that
have child c groups and so on in other
words a tree of c groups that's one part
of it and the other thing is controllers
in other words kernel components
that can do
resource
resource measurement
some kind of control
on groups of processes rather than
individual processes
so it's those two pieces and as i
mentioned already the interface is via a
pseudo file system
uh which means you interact with c
groups using in the ways you would
normally interact with a file system you
could do it from the shell and that's
what i'll do in a few examples or you
could write a program that does is or
you could use a daemon that does it for
you like system d system d
has an interface for controlling c
groups
and of course the container frameworks
themselves are
under the covers
using c groups to do their management of
processes inside containers
what sort of things can you do
one possibility is limiting resource
usage to say that this group of
processes only gets a certain percentage
of one cpu or this group of processes
only gets a certain amount of memory
or a certain amount of network bandwidth
conversely you might turn things around
and prioritize some group of processes
so they get more of a resource perhaps
they get favored for the network
bandwidth for their outgoing network
traffic
some of the controllers
or some of the features of some of the
controllers are just about doing
resource measurement how much cpu time
is this group of processors consuming or
how much memory are they consuming
currently
and then there's some
sort of funky controllers things like
the freezer controller what the freezer
controller lets you do is say this group
of processors
freeze them take them off the cpu
off the cpu run queue the processors
still exist they're just not getting cpu
time until later on you thaw them
and there are some use cases for this to
do with containers
so a bit of terminology we've got the
idea of a control group or a c group
what i mean by that is a group of
processes that are being bound together
for the purposes of resource management
in other words
this group of processes sharing a memory
allocation or sharing a cpu location
but together
their use is being measured against that
allocation rather than as individual
processes
then we've got the notion of a resource
controller and what i mean by a resource
controller is a component inside the
kernel that does
some sort of resource limitation
or resource measurement or some other
kind of management of groups of
processes
so for instance there's a memory
controller that limits memory
consumption or a cpu controller that
limits cpu consumption
sometimes in documentation and inside
the kernel source code you'll see
another term being used synonymously a
subsystem
people talk about c group subsystems i
don't really like this term very much it
is quite common
problem for me is that the word
subsystem is so generic as to be almost
meaningless so i prefer the term
resource controller
and the point about these c groups they
are arranged in a hierarchy each c group
can have child c groups which have child
c groups and this hierarchy is
meaningful so that for instance if you
impose a limit on a high level c group
that limit applies to the lower level c
groups as well
the interface as i've mentioned already
it's a file system and you interact with
this file system obviously doing file
system operations for example to create
a c group what you do is make a
directory on the file system simply the
act of making a directory creates a new
c group
when you want to get rid of that c group
you remove the directory
each one of these directory directories
that we create
has some
automatically created files
and these files are used for a couple of
purposes one is
to manage the c group itself
things like which processes are members
of the c group
and the other thing is to do the
resource limitation functionality there
are various files that you can whose
values you can update to set limits for
the processes inside this
c group
some of the other files are doing things
like exposing information about the c
group how much memory is being consumed
how much cpu is being consumed and so on
so let's try an example and i have got
some slides here but it's
so much more fun to do a live demo
because things could go wrong
[Music]
that's what everyone's here for really
the mistakes
um let's uh
try some stuff out so what i'm going to
do is some experiments with the pids
controller
and now i mentioned already that the
file system is mounted at a location
like this
and
the file system is owned by super user
so i'm going to do all of these commands
as super user so i'm just going to start
up a
super user shell
it's a noisy prompt
okay
so
then
i'm going to
make a directory which i'll call
my group
now
i'm going to put this shell into that
group
at least in a moment
um now the
i want to check one or two things first
though
sis
already in that directory i didn't need
to do that but i can just
okay i've got a range of controllers
available to me i'll talk about some of
these controllers a bit later on some of
these controllers are enabled i'll talk
about these details a bit later on as
well what i wanted to just check there
is that the pids controller is enabled
and that means that i can do pids
control in the child c group and so what
i'm going to do
is move this shell
into that c group
and the way i do that is by writing a
pid into a file inside that directory
so
the files see
procs so now this shell
is in that c group
one of things you can do with any
process on the system
is cat
the file proc pid
c group
um cap the file proctored c group and
you can discover the c group membership
of the corresponding process
and
what i see there is some colon delimited
fields
if i was using a system that had both
secrets version one and secrets version
two i'd see several records in this file
but because i've booted up into secrets
version two only mode which is the
default on fedora
i see just one line here and that is the
line the one that begins zero colon
colon is the line that tells me about c
groups version two and this is telling
me that in the secrets version two
hierarchy this process is a member of
the c group
with the path slash my group where my
group of course is relative to the mount
point
now
that files
cgroup.prox
in the
c group that i've just placed this shell
in
we can write pids into that file to add
processes to that cgroup we also read
that file and we see the
the pids of the member processes now one
of those pids of course is the pid of
the shell
guest is about what the other one is
martin
okay it's the cat process because the
cat process was created as a child of
the shell
and
child processes when they're created
start their life in the same
c group as their
as the parent process
at least that's how it's always been
until relatively recently there is
nowadays a feature that the limits
kernel has and this was added in the
last year or so where you can say i want
to create a new process that starts its
life in a different c group it's an
option of the clone 3 system call some
people wanted that functionality
okay
now
inside that file inside that directory
that's the wrong file i'm looking at
there's another file
and this is a file that relates to the
pids controller and this tells me how
many processes are there in this c group
okay there's two one of them is the
shell of course another one is this cat
command that was just running there
momentarily
now there is another file
in that directory
called
i meant to say
cat
called pids.max
and this allows me to find out what is
the limit of the number of pids in the c
group
and
has the string max in at the moment
which means there's no limit inside this
c group but i'm going to put a limit in
there so i'm going to say echo
greater
video ids.max
just verify that change
okay limit's now 5
and then i'm going to say for
[Music]
j in
seek
one
five in other words five times
to run a sleep process
uh
sleep for 60 seconds
in the background and done
now what happened was that the loop
managed to create four sleep processes
but when it tried to create the fifth
we'd already hit the limit of processes
inside the c group now what bash is
trying to now do now is retries i
couldn't create a process and it's gonna
try again a few times and then it then
it gives up
okay but the point is
i've
reached the limit of processes inside
that c group
i could if i wanted to say
cat pids dot current let's find out how
many processes are in the c group i
could try that
but of course
the cap process is a child of the shell
so i can't create a cap process inside
that c group but what i can do
and did i i should have carefully noted
the pid of my shell back there
it is this pid
what i can do is from a shell that is in
the in
the root c group the root
pid or the root c group i could then
instead say cat
slash prop pids
p ideas dot
no i'm getting confused what am i doing
i'm saying i should be i i've got myself
a bit confused there cis fs
c group
now i'm going to race against time of
course because 60 seconds will run out
soon
okay i was too late
okay let's try that again
run that loop
okay and then
down below
i've had the limit okay
five processors in this group and the
limit is five processes
okay i think i've covered everything's
on these following slides now let me
just double check
yes
oh one more thing
um
to remove a c group i just remove the
directory
so i could now
let's just my sleep processes are still
running by the look of it
yes
i could now say to remove the c group
which was called my group
wrong window wrong window
um
i remember
i better go down here and become super
user down here as well
[Music]
c group my group
now
that failed because
the
cigarette i'm trying to remove is not
empty
in other words it either has child c
groups or member processes or both
in this case it's got a member process
because the upper shell the shell on the
top window is a member of that c group
so what i'm now going to do is move that
oh well i can't do it that way can i oh
no no hang on no yes i can
echo dollar dollar
into
um
cgroup
1. just to make this clear i'll write
out the full path name
okay
why did that work by the way
why i couldn't run a cat command up
there before oh no i'm starting that's
true i'm not at the limit anymore but
even if i had been at the limit i could
have done this
because echo is a shell built in it
doesn't create another process
okay now
if i now look at
cis
fs
c group
my group p ids pids.current
there's no member processes
so now with a bit of luck
i can remove that c group and it's gone
one of the things i didn't have to do
inside that directory i didn't actually
show we saw a few files inside that
directory things like pids.com
pids.max and so on and secret.procs i
didn't have to remove those files before
i remove directory
you can't remove those files if you try
to you get an error okay but those are
just magic files that were made up on
the fly by the kernel anyway and it's
making up its own rules about what we
can do about this do with the strength
tree and in this case for c group
territories it says yeah you can delete
those directories even if it looks like
they have member fire member files
okay so
quickly then to look at what controllers
do we have what sort of things can we
control
with with c groups
and we've got a few different
controllers
there is
by the way in the kernel source tree a
documentation file that talks about the
various controllers
what have we got we've got a cpu
controller what the cpu controller does
of course is let you all let you do two
things really limit cpu usage and also
measure cpu usage and the cpu controller
has a couple of modes of operation
there's a so called shares mode or
proportional weight division mode which
is uh the default mode and there's
another mode called bandwidth control
and you can mix these two modes at
different levels in the hierarchy if you
want
now
the way that the proportional weight
division mode works is
at each level in the tree or in each
branch of the tree there's a bunch of
siblings at the same level here i've got
a b and c
and each one of those
um
c groups has some sort of weighting it
was called shares in version one it's
called weight in version two and what
happens is all the shares at one level
are added together to make a total and
then each c group gets its share of the
total so
the total error of a b and c of course
is 4096
and uh that would mean that
the prices in cba are going to get one
quarter of the overall cpu time the
processes in b are going to get one half
and the process in c again again going
to get one quarter
it's a hierarchical controller they're
all hierarchical controls but the the
limits are hierarchical so
the resources that are distributed into
b
can be further subdivided at lower
levels so in the c group x and the c
group y we've got some weight values of
one thousand and four thousand this
means that the processes in c group x
would get one-fifth
of one-half
one-tenth of the overall cpu time the
processes and y would get
four-fifths of one-half four-tenths of
the overall cpu time
so on and so on you can further
subdivide as many times you like using
this this shares this weight mechanism
the way that this mechanism works by the
way it only the limits only apply if
there is competition for the cpu so for
instance
if there are no processors in the
branches b and c that are trying to use
the cpu but the processes in
ni are trying to use the cpu flat out
they'll get a hundred percent of the cpu
the the limits only apply if there is
competition
now there is another mode which is
what's called bandwidth control and
bandwidth control really is strict
limits even if no one else is using the
cpu you don't get more than your
allocation
and the way that the bandwidth control
mode works is
the the proportion of cpu that the
processors get is expressed as two
numbers
a quota and a period and the quota
divided by the period of course
expresses a fraction and that's the
fraction of cpu that the processes in
this c group receive
so here for example i'm assuming that in
every one of these c groups the period
is one hundred thousand
um
the
the the
processes in c group p would get twenty
percent of the overall cpu time
also i'll rephrase that 20 at most 20
percent of the cpu time
um
oh sorry i've jumped down level the
process in a would get 50
below that the process in p would get 20
percent prices in q would get 40 process
in r would get 10 percent and yes
there's some funniness in those numbers
there
the children of i are over subscribed
they've said that overall they can get
70 percent of the cpu but the parent can
only get 50 percent
so
if p q and r if the process is there all
trying to use cpu they won't get 70
because there is a higher level limit
that says
in this tree
and as i say this applies even if there
is no competition for the cpu which is
nice for hosting providers to say things
like you know you paid for this much cpu
that's all you're going to get even if
no one else is using the cpu
there's other controllers there's a
controller called the cpu set controller
what this
lets you do is choose the cpu affinity
and the memory affinity of a group of
processes choose which cpus a group of
processors is going to use and there's a
couple of reasons that you might do this
one is that maybe you want to force most
processes off a certain cpu so that some
process that really needs to seep that
cpu always has that cpu available to it
another possibility is you're on a numa
system non-uniform memory access system
these are boxes you know with very large
numbers of cpus you know maybe 1024 cpus
and the cpus are organized into nodes
where maybe there are 16 cpus in a node
each node has associated memory
and
if a process
execute well i'll rephrase it if a
process xq on a certain cpu uses memory
in the local bank this is more efficient
all the cpus can access all the memory
on all the nodes but accessing local
memory is
faster
so it is desirable to ensure that in a
newer environment
processes related processes run on the
same node and they use memory associated
with that same node for reasons of
efficient memory access this is one of
the things that you can
bring about using the cpu set controller
we've got a memory controller memory
control lets you limit
the amount of memory that is being used
by a group of processors and for each c
group you can set up a couple of limits
a so-called soft limit if the processes
go over that soft limit they'll start
getting swapped out if there is memory
pressure
and there's a hard limit and if
processors go over the hard limit then
the um killer comes out to play the um
killer out of memory killer is a kernel
component that is designed to relieve
low memory situations by choosing a
victim a process to be eliminated and
therefore freeing up memory for the
other processes
the killer is
it's just a dumb kernel component what i
mean is it doesn't have any intelligence
about people's applications it picks a
victim
there is an alternative with the memory
controller where you can say
um
if memory gets low
send a notification to a user space
process
and the user space process might make a
more sensible decision about how to deal
with the low memory situation like
saying picking which process to kill for
example or telling various processes you
know it's you know we we're consuming
too much memory you should terminate or
you should release some memory in order
to relieve this low memory situation
other controllers there's an i o
controller what this is about is
limiting i o bandwidth
to block devices things like
ssds hard disk drives and so on
um and
you can
uh again but like this the cpu control
there's two kinds of limitation that you
can do um proportional weight division
or
absolute throttling of the traffic
and you can do this on a per device
basis of course
there's a devices controller
this is one that is quite important for
containers because one of things that
you typically want to do in a container
is ensure that containers
only can access a very limited set of
devices and this is what the devices
controller allows you to do to choose
which
devices
the processes in a certain c group are
allowed to
access
for instance in a container a typical
use case is to ensure that processors
can only access say devices null xero
full random and maybe one or two others
the devices controller looks very
different in secrets version two than
what was done in secrets version one and
secrets version two the way that this
control is done is with an ebpf program
i like to say you're not a cool kid
kernel developer these days if you're
not trying to do something with ebpf
because everyone's trying to do it
and the way that this ebpf program works
you can attach an ebpf program to a c
group and when a process inside the c
group tries to access the device open a
device or create a device the kernel
kicks the bpf program into action and
the bpf program makes a decision is that
kind of device access allowed or not
okay
we can do network traffic control with
um with
um c groups as well
nowadays and well i'll rephrase that
with secrets version two there is now
the facility to attach again an ebpf
program to c groups and the ebpf program
does shaping of the network traffic so
you can cause some c groups
network traffic to be favored or
disfavored
there's a pids controller i've just
shown you that one limit the number of
pids in a c group of course that's uh
interesting for people who like to
prevent
containers
creating fork bombs that overrun the
system
there's a freezer controller and i
mentioned this one briefly already
what it allows you to do is freeze a
group of processors take them off the
cpu run queue
until they're later thawed and then they
put back on the run queue again and they
can
do stuff execute
this is useful uh in particular due to
to do with container migration use cases
the idea that you take a container
running on one physical system and move
it over to run on another physical
system perhaps because you're going to
shut down the first system but you want
to keep the process inside the container
running so you want to migrate the
container
and there's a whole lot of work that
needs to happen to make that work
but the infrastructure is there part of
the infrastructure is you know when we
finally decide that we're ready to move
the processes over the other system we
want to freeze the process in the
container and then move them over to the
other system
there's a few other container
controllers i'm not going to try and
talk about any sort of detail but i just
mentioned there are two or three other
controllers as well
now
we've got
i glossed over at the start
a detail about enabling and disabling
controls and the point is that every in
every c group directory there are two
um
two files c group dot controllers and c
group dot subtree control and
the first file tells us what controllers
are available in this c group and the
other one says which of those available
controllers is enabled
the reason these two files exist is
to allow us to manage different
controllers
to different depths within the tree in
other words managed controllers to
different levels of granularity with
respect to the processes on the system
so if we look inside the
seagroup.controllers file we'll see some
list of controllers here now i i was
just talking about the controllers
before and i said there were about a
dozen what you probably didn't count
them but there are about a dozen
controllers
and yet when you look inside this file
inside the root c group you probably see
a small a smaller number well you will
see a smaller number of um controllers
and there's a couple of reasons why you
might not see
so many controllers
in this file one of them is
some controllers might also be in use in
secrets version one and this is one of
the points c group version two is
designed so it can co-exist with c
groups version one
subject to a restriction which is if you
use a controller in secrets version one
you can't use it in secrets version 2.
so if i was on a system that had both
secrets version 1 and secrets version 2
available
and i was using a certain controller on
secrets version 1 then i wouldn't see it
in the cgroup.controllers file in the
root of the version 2 hierarchy
so this is one reason why i might not
see some controllers there
there's another reason uh which is
uh well sorry there's another reason
i'll come to in a moment but that was i
was thinking of something else for a
moment another reason you might not see
a c group i'm sorry a controller in a
certain c group is it's not enabled in
the parent c group
but
there's also a certain set of
controllers that are the so-called
implicit controllers they are always
available everywhere in the version 2
hierarchy they don't need to be enabled
or disabled they're always available
and because they're always available
they are not listed in this
cgroup.control file so example an
example of an implicit controller is the
freezer controller it's always available
now
maybe rather than walking through slides
i will show an example
so just here i'm in the
root c group
uh my current director is the root c
group
and
if i can't
see group
dot
controllers there's a certain set of
controllers that are available
and if i can't
subtree control there's a certain set of
controllers that are enabled at this
level now
the idea here is that if i enable a
controller at a certain level then i can
do the corresponding control at the next
level down
so what i'm going to do now is well in
fact no before i do that i'll make a
child c group um
i'll call it group one
now i'm going to look inside that child
c group that i just created
there's a certain set of files there
certain set of interface files now
i'm just going to refine that slightly
that output
the files that have the prefix cpu now
these two files they just give us
statistics about
cpu usage
in the c group these files are always
present in every c group
there are also files that are used by
the cpu controller but they are not
present in this
cigarette mode because the cpu
controller is not enabled at the level
above
okay just to remind you
at the level above the cpu controller is
not enabled it's available but it's not
enabled
so if i now turn around and enable that
controller at the level above
and the way i do that is by writing
a certain string into the
subtree control file i've chosen the
wrong
string of course
i and then just verify that change
okay we now see cpu there and now if i
look in
group 1 for the files cpu.star
a whole bunch of other files have just
appeared
those files have been created because i
enabled the controller at the level
above so that now i can do control in
the next level down
and
so now for example i could
run a program down here
i've got a little program that burns up
cpu time and
tells us how much cpu time is being
uh what percentage of cpu time the
process is getting and at the moment
it's getting you know 100 of the cpu
that it wants
now
up above
i'm now going to say
echo
let's say
twenty thousand
one hundred
thousand this is the quota and the
period that that expresses that fraction
that i was talking about before when i
was talking about the cpu controller i'm
going to put that into
group
cpu.max
just count that file
okay
the numbers are there
and then i'm going to move the process
down below into that c group
so
in
into group one
slash
c group dot prox
and
yeah okay we're gonna quickly enough
converge to 20
cpu usage
okay
now
just continuing on from this um
uh
this idea a little bit more at each
level we can enable a controller in
order to do control at the next level
down
now if i look at the next level down in
the group in the file group one
at the cgroup dot controllers file
i see a certain set of controllers
available
they are the ones that were enabled at
the level above
okay
just to remind you there if i say cat
sub tree control at the level above
okay those were the ones that were
enabled at the level above so they uh
sorry yeah they enabled the level above
so they're available at the next level
down
if i look at the next level down
to see which controllers are
enabled
to begin with no controllers are enabled
at that level
so what that means is if i created the
grandchild c group
one group two
and then looked inside that directory
i'd see a small set of files there
these are files that appear in every c
group directory but there are no
interface files that let me do any sort
of control because none of the
controllers are enabled at the level
above
but if i now said echo
plus pids into
group
into group one
slash
c group
uh procs did i do
actually i really meant to say cpu but
uh
yes uh yeah
okay
it's been a busy week already
um
into subtree control
and then look in the grandchild
c group
now a whole bunch of cpu file cpu
related files have appeared and this
allows me to do cpu control at the next
level down
likewise if i now said plus
pids
now when looking at
grandchild directory there's some pids
files that have appeared
on the other hand
if
i
tried to enable the i o controller
i get an error and that's because at
this level the i o controller is not an
available controller because it was not
enabled at the level above
so what these two files the controllers
file and the subtree control file are
enabling us to do is to enable different
controllers to different
depths in different branches of the
hierarchy and this enables us to do the
so-called granularity use case where
certain controls weren't managed to a
certain depth
a certain we want to perhaps want to
manage
we want fine-grained control of cpu
allocation to processes but we don't
care so much about fine grain control of
memory allocation
so we have the memory controller enabled
to a certain depth in the hierarchy but
the cpu controller enabled at lower
levels so that we can make fine-grained
decisions about cpu allocation to
processes
is it is it strictly tree-like or can a
child group have
permissions that its parent doesn't have
i i presume what you mean by permissions
is uh make use of controllers that is
parent and
that is the point that for these uh
explicit controls things like cpu and
and memory and so on the answer is no
and that's that's the very point
it has to come through the parent there
are these implicit controllers that are
always available everywhere
but
for controllers like cpu and memory and
io
they can only be used at a lower level
if they were enabled at a level at the
level above
the parent needs to have that controller
enabled the middle layer would need to
have the controller enabled
okay
i think i've covered pretty much what
what is on the slides just let me just
double check
yes we did an example and i've talked
about this granularity use case and
so the idea here is that we might enable
some controllers to a certain depth
other controls to a deeper depth simply
because we want to manage resources to
different levels of granularity
and this is part of our design
and that's as much as i have to say for
now but i'll take questions
yes please
yes yes
yeah
let's try that let's try that
so
we've currently got a limit of 20 there
so but
if i now
see where is that line
there we are
i could change that to
okay so
let's just
view the situation that we have yes so
in
group
one c group dot controllers
cpu is enable is available and
it is
in
enabled
that's for the children of group one but
of course the process down below is is
inside group one let's let's um
try saying echo
minus
cpu
in
group one
c group dot subtree control
okay
now that's but that's for the children
of group one this hasn't affect the
processes that are in group one yeah
now then the question is
if i s disabled the cpu controller
in the
root c group
okay
control's been taken away
christian
ah it's a nice question so if you've got
some existing processes and you
uh enable a pid limit for the for the
process already in an existing c group
what happens
the what the pids controller is doing is
limiting the creation of new processes
the existing processes are uneffective
now you might have set a limit of say 10
in a certain secret maybe there are 15
processes in the c group already that's
fine they'll stay and even the system
administrator could move more processes
in there if they wanted to by writing
pids into the c group or proxima but if
any one of those processes tried to
create a child process
the fork call would fail
there would be an error
martin
you mentioned
yes
so the question was is the the i
mentioned that clone three it's the
clone three system call has a facility
for saying i want to create a child
process in a different c group from the
parent a different version to c group
um the way that you specify the c group
that you want to create the process in
is
you open a file descriptor
for a particular cgroup directory
you would need to have permission to do
that
now
so not just anyone can do this sort of
stuff
other questions
yes please you're the first person's
name i don't know
it's specifically devices yeah device
inodes
um
no but
you're probably interested in other
kinds of tools potentially things like
sc linux or app armor
secrets
isn't the job isn't this isn't the job
it isn't the thing for this job
hello i don't know your name either but
hey
um
ah
you want to come back in the next hour
the answer is yes
yes it's a feature called delegation
thomas
yes you are sitting on that side of the
room i ran a class at the beginning of
this week and
thomas knew ikea was sitting on the same
well the program the programmatic
aspect of it is you know people
sometimes say to me is there a
c groups api
and i say yes open
close
read and write
and and yeah
people have in the past
invented apis but those apis never seem
to have really taken off
um i think they just didn't do the job
well enough or give enough extra
functionality beyond just
doing it yourself
perhaps a more common way that people
might interact with
c groups these days programmatically is
via systemd
because systemd has some interfaces for
doing this sort of thing
hello
you have to sorry you have to speak up
for me i'm just a little bit i'm sorry
we saw content in there right
yeah and remember these aren't real
files they're just made up by the kernel
and the kernel shows you what it wants
to show you
yeah in
a consistent way
well you might say you might say that
you know real files the real disk files
wasn't made up by the computer at least
i like to think of it that way
some things are more made up than others
other questions
i think we're about on the hour now oh
and i've got a couple of minutes
so i will talk about some other features
in the next hour one of them is
delegation
um
another one what are the oh gee i forgot
what other things i'm going to talk
about a thread mode
and
delegation thread mode and
something else
okay more detail about secrets version 2
basically
alrighty thank you
[Applause]